what is up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio fantastic Fest
20123 I'm so excited this is our last
interview of the festival and it's with
the collider Alum who made a movie Clark
Wolf the shining example oh hi I'm so
glad that we're getting to do this this
is the coolest thing ever that I'm
sitting here interviewing you for your
short film it's such a nice full circle
moment and I'm so so honored so thank
you for having me meant to be especially
after we've had many a discussion about
The Shining too on top of that yes I saw
even on Twitter that our shining YouTube
channel or YouTube video popped up again
it comes up a lot yeah and I was like
well we shall be reuniting to talk about
the shining very soon okay so I know
what the shining example is but a lot of
people out there don't just yet so can
you give a brief synopsis of your short
I can the way I've been sort of
explaining it in like one line is The
Shining with a mom and and you know the
origin of that was as you know and as
the audience knows you know I have been
talking about movies and analyzing
movies specifically horror movies for a
very long time we've talked about The
Shining many many times and so I I was
doing a show on my a twitch Channel
called fear HQ and where we were
breaking down you know genre films and
so I did the shining and I did uh
Sinister and then I started kind of
picking up on I was like you know there
are a lot of movies made and there are a
lot of genre movies made specifically
about creatively frustrated dads who
take that out on their family but I
don't think I've ever seen that with a
mom and what does that look like and so
that is that is sort of where it kind of
came from not I mean this is not a mom
but your film paired with stop motion
just in terms of like a creatively like
frustrated woman who's trying to find
her own voice and break through it's
just the perfect pair I was so thrilled
when I first of all when I submitted a
fantastic Fest I did not know if I was
going to get in obviously been coming
here for many years and and wanted this
to be my world premiere but there was no
guarantee the shorts competition here is
very tough and then when we were
accepted that was amazing but then I
found out we were paired with a feature
and I was like oh my God what a
compliment and I read the synopsis and I
went wow this is great how how they are
they're so different they're wildly
different and yet the broad Strokes were
really compatible so it it was a really
fabulous on Sunday night when we did
have the world premiere it was my world
premiere and Robert Morgan's for stop Mo
stop motion and um it was a really cool
experience to get to see kind of come
together oh I could imagine all right so
you have acted in many a film this is
your first time as a director though on
one right yes so I mean uh during coid I
was working like hang you know a friend
of mine who actually co-produced this
movie buz wallik um he created something
called just scare me and so the point of
this is just make a short film it's a it
just has to have a scare in it it's a
collaborative sort of teamwork thing
it's an accountability group it's not a
contest just every two months make a
short film sign up and make a short film
so it's really um and it's just about
doing it so he encouraged me to do
something so I had directed you know
like two iPhones two wers they're
together in a zoom call or like a Skype
call or whatever um so that was the but
that's it two runners two iPhones I mean
there's no crew or or produ production
value or any of that and um so when this
this is the first time I've ever done
anything like this with a real budget
and a real crew and real people behind
it and and so I was so happy to get to
bring Buzz along for that but yeah it
was it was the first time ever doing
anything like this so choosing your
first project as a director is a big
deal what was it about this particular
story and these themes that you thought
aligned well with the skill set you
already had as a filmmaker that's a
great question I mean well here's a you
so I act in the movie as well and I
should say that um the shorts just for
your audience in case in case they don't
know um the short shorts contract with
sag and the wga is not struck yes um so
but of course I certainly am a member of
sag and I support uh all of my you know
brothers and sisters and family and all
of the unions and hope that the SAG
feature and TV um agreement will come
soon but that said um I you know
I wanted this to be my first thing with
a real budget and a real team because I
felt like I had something to say I I
felt like especially in the genre space
you know like this type of um
acknowledging sort of a a part of a part
of the human existence and like
relationships and motherhood and things
like that I don't feel like I've seen it
before so that is a big part of why I
really wanted this to be the first thing
and I do act in the movie and there's
part that you know part of it was
creating the roles that you want to see
like that you would want to play
yourself um but also part of it was I
have two days there is no room for error
here and I know at the very least I will
know my lines I will know my marks like
you know what I mean so two days my God
two days yeah two days anxiety just
hearing that yeah 15 page script in two
days I have so many follow-up questions
the first one because you did refer to
the as your first time working with a
real budget which I very much understand
what is the first like real budget like
crew member or like piece of gear or
something that you acquired that made
you think I'm so excited to get to use
this wow that's such a good question too
you know for me I will admit um going
into this I you know as an actor when
you're on camera you need to know your
lenses you need to know your angle like
there are certain parts of the technical
aspect of being an actor in film and
television that you you need to pay
attention to the gear and those types of
things but I will be honest with you
that is not my forte um however it is
very much Zack vitus's Forte who is my
DP and Zach was it was the first time I
had ever met him we did not know each
other before but we hit it off so well
and we really spoke this like communal
language of movies so like you know I'm
sure you probably picked up on some of
the lighting the dinner table Scene It
Feels Like hereditary in a lot of ways
that was intentional you know the warm
colors and all and then you know there
was one moment while we were on set
where something wasn't quite working and
Z said what about this and I'll give you
that Sam Ry thing that you like and I
was like yes exactly thank you you get
it so Zack voitus was really for my
money like the biggest best find that I
could and you know real talk um I was
intimidated have as a director not that
I didn't know that I couldn't get the
shots and I knew what I wanted of course
and I and I knew how to work with actors
of course so I felt good about all that
but what I was nervous about was a crew
looking at me like she doesn't even know
anything about lenses is she a real
director and Zach never ever ever made
me feel that way when we were setting up
shots when we were doing the walk
through he would say okay come over here
look at this tell me what you think do
you like that so Zach was just the most
wonderful collaborator and I want him to
shoot everything I ever make for the
rest of time what a wonderful quality
cuz we do also emphasize the of having a
director who's a leader that brings
everyone in their Vision together but
it's also important for it to go the
other way and for a director to feel
well supported so they have the
confidence to actually do that part of
the job yes I mean that and and I this
crew was outstanding um and there were
so many people from our Circle Holly
pain in the costumes uh which was really
really fun there's so many people that
kind of came to play which was great but
yes I feel like what I learned on this
set was hire the best people you can and
then you kind of that's your job to make
it all work is is really just to hire
people who commun you've got to
communicate exactly what you want so
they know their job and then let them go
do what their job is and and that was I
think one of the things that I really
loved about directing was like yeah I
feel comfortable delegating and I trust
you to do what it is that you're here to
do it's really just management you know
so and then of course the creative part
it's all about being creative but also
being like kind human beings and
actually turning your into a family or
at least I'm a big believer that that
should and that's I hope that we created
that environment on set I get the sense
that you did okay so you're directing
and you're also starring in this very
experienced actor what is something you
learned about the craft of acting by
finally getting behind the lens and
directing actors so something that I
think is really interesting especially
during coid I'm sure you you all have
heard about self tapes so this has
become super common now when it comes to
auditioning and so really most actors at
this point are directing themselves when
they're auditioning um so this whole you
know I always encourage actors to get
over this whole thing of like I don't
like watching myself it's like well
welcome to self tapes you're going to
have to watch every little thing for the
rest of time but um what I learned about
acting from directing myself in this
capacity was to have people on the other
side of the camera that you trust so
like you know to use the example of my
producer Buzz directed me in things
before he felt very we had decided
beforehand okay if you think I if you
catch something that I don't we need
another one can lean over and say you
need another one uh and so we but the
other thing I would I would do next time
that I didn't quite do is when you're in
it you're you're thinking about a
million things but then it's time to
focus on the acting I would write myself
Direction notes on my script so that I
could look at them before we started
rolling and went yes that's that's right
I wanted to think about this or I wanted
to remember this and then put that away
just because your your brain is just all
over the place so I kind of direct
myself on paper a little bit so that I
could forget like or didn't for you know
didn't forget but that that was
something that I think I'm going to try
on the next one okay one more uh
directing actor's question for you again
experienced actor what is something a
past director has done for you as an
actor's director that you wanted to do
for your cast but then I want the
opposite something that you wish more
actors directors did that you made sure
to channel here oh wow okay well Anthony
deblasi who directed
malum uh there's something that's going
to come out on the
Blu-ray uh that you will be able to see
he got the coverage he needed I'll speak
as a director Anthony when he directs he
gets what he needs and then he uh throws
you a curveball if he's got time he's
like now let's just try something and um
so as a director Anthony did that on the
set of malum in a Safeway of course it
was Performance Based not like you know
stunt based or or special effects based
and they rolled on it and it's going to
be uh it's going to be on the BL and
I've seen it and I was like I it it I
felt like I was like wow that's actually
me acting and um and and it was really
special so love a curveball what a
beautiful reaction to have to something
like that too it was love that I I Adore
Anthony deasy and and um would will do
anything with him forever uh but um so I
like when as a director when I've got it
I like letting act because I am an actor
I like letting actors um not play around
I like giving them some an alt and then
seeing what they do with it so in this
film uh Andy Cohen who plays Jeff uh
Andy's an incredible
uh actor he's a director himself but um
there's a scene where towards the end
where Jeff is really um he's he's very
he's not listening and then you see him
listen for the first
time and if you do know which moment I'm
talking about okay and so um you know he
was doing it just how I needed it you
know giving me like checked out giving
me aloof giving me whatever and the
direction I gave him was okay now I want
him to hear her and and really
understand what she's saying and that's
the take that's in the movie um and
everyone on set kind of was like oh wow
well now we feel bad for him and and so
you'll you'll see it eventually but it
was a beautiful moment so I I wish more
at more directors did that and then um
anded something I was able to do on my
set as well I love that I love that all
right before we wind down I want to make
sure to touch on the post production
here a little because there's a lot of
editing choices that are absolutely
vital to to putting you in her head more
so than just the material that was shot
on set during production so how much did
you have all of that mapped out and
storyboarded and how much did you wind
up finding in the edit when you can
actually play around with things like
Quick Cuts color changes all that kind
of stuff yeah uh so there there I will
tell you one thing I did not get uh was
a clean shot of the door and that seems
like 101 directing 101 the door to uh to
these offices to these rooms in this
house become are are very important
because what's going on behind the doors
whether it's um with my character Aiden
or with uh Andy's character Jeff but
nonetheless um I missed that one oops
it's always something it's always
something little that you don't realize
yep but we figured it out and by we I
mean Tom Newell so Tom is just an a
veteran of genre editing he is an editor
on Chucky he's an editor on uh for the
VHS films post production supervisor I
mean Tom is an incredible editor and he
knows the genre so well so we really
played around with certain certain
things uh and and then got creative if
we didn't have something we uh we fudged
it a little uh I can give you an example
there's a dinner table scene we we shot
in this beautiful uh home and it has
these beautiful archways and I wanted to
push through the doorways and the family
is far away in the background um and I
realized we we like got it going in but
we didn't get it going out so we just
the same take and we reversed it makes
all the sense You' never know and edit
and it looks great and it worked and
with the oh I'll tell you a funny story
okay so um as you know in The Shining
croquet Mallet is a big issue is a big
uh a big prop in the novel so we have a
cro set one another thing I made a
mistake about and this was my fault are
we have an incredible production
designer allur uh and she uh so she got
gets the croquet set and um and you know
different colors on the mallets and um
so you know Aiden's color is red uh you
know the daughter's characters purple
like there's all those little color
schemes okay uh then I realized is these
are teeny croquet mallets they're real
small this is going to look real
silly and that was another thing where I
was like yeah and I approved this I
approved this hero prop oops but as a
result we were able to shoot it in such
a way and then we were also Tom and I
were able to fudge a little bit like
push in a couple times to make it look a
little bigger so that you don't really
catch that I I didn't notice that's for
sure good that that means we Tom we did
it that's what making movies is about
it's about doing what you think is best
in the moment but working with what you
got and we have so many credible like
tools and creative minds that you can
kind of make anything work now I love
that it was great we found a lot of that
in post so that was but in terms of like
the visions and and getting inside
aden's head a lot of that is through
Visual style and of course we replicated
a lot you know throwback to Stanley
Kubrick's imagery which you will see
when you when you see the short and um
and so on but we so we knew that that
was going to be a part of it we were we
were directly nodding at Stanley
Kubrick's film um and and the way he
lets you inside of what's going on um
but then of course I think that there
are moments um that are more emotional
that hopefully that hopefully are you go
a little deeper with Aiden versus maybe
Jack very very effective all right
you're getting one of my last questions
that I've liked asking during most of
these interviews because this is my
first fantastic Fest I'm so I can't
believe that I'm a little I'm a little
shocked it took this long I'm glad it
finally happened and now I get what
everybody else tells me about it and I
have a feeling I'm going to need to come
back over and over and over again
defitely will it is a community of
horror lovers who are happy to be here
to support each other but I've also
heard so many stories about people
seeing something being inspired and
feeling like they need to go off and
create something else can you pinpoint
something you saw in somebody else's
movie that made you go damn that's cool
and I am inspired by it oh my gosh oh my
go the the example I always think of
with fantastic Fest is just burned into
my brain is a is a Mexican genre film
called We Are The
Flesh uh I don't know if you've seen it
okay I saw that here I saw that here and
it was a close to a midnight screening
and I was like wow just wow I will never
forget this and and um you know those
types of that's what I come to Fantastic
Fest for you know there's even there's a
movie called better watch out that I had
a very negative reaction to in the
theater and I remember talking to the
programmers via email about like they
were like you know somebody they were
being very curious and and sensitive but
they were like you know do you think we
shouldn't have shown this and I said oh
no no no no no no you absolutely should
have that's why I come here to be
challenged and and so you know that's
what I love about about exploitation and
genre and and all of that is is yeah I'm
seeing things and experiencing things
that are meant to make me uncomfortable
um and and challenge the way that I see
things and I do things so I bring these
examples up because they're they're
things that I'll never forget and they
are inspiring you know you come here and
you see things from all over the world
and what other people are doing and uh
you know it's it's it's inspirational uh
all over New forging new ground within
genre is what I come here to see so so
true I'm addicted to this place I want
to come back the only thing that might
hold me back from getting a tattoo
tonight is that I'm convinced I'm going
to come back in the future so maybe I
want to leave the door open for other
options down the live you're going to
well you know that you people have like
sleeves of all the little ones kind of
so you be that I'm prone to doing stuff
what you're supposed to keep me in check
right now oh I'm sorry you're right
think twice about it don't do it I've
literally signed away my life for
everything this Festival has to offer I
am so so glad I got to see your movie
and celebrate with you and have you back
on the collider YouTube channel
congratulations as always I rooting for
you thank you Perry This was such a
wonderful full circle moment and I can't
thank you enough for your support thank
you